[inaudible] live.
We're back.
I bet.
Yeah.
We came back.
Well,
Mons and Marquez Lmo Brian.
Brian would connect.
Correct?
You were gonna we were trying
to watch the fade or fight.
We've got to get a new
apple TV up in this bitch.
We got this old shit.
We gotta get the new one.
The new one has a better remote.
Oh yeah,
I got the new one.
I tried to download the road,
use the remote APP,
but he gets,
it only works on one apple TV.
Can't use it.
The one you have somewhere else.
It's not effective.
What does marijuana,
it's just bad for what does this,
uh,
we're going to watch the,
fade or Fabio Maldonado
fight in its entirety.
Entirety,
Huh?
Yeah.
Is this fine?
I believe it's 13 good.
Hey,
y'all give me,
if you get panicky,
fast forward.
I've seen him.
I know.
Had He,
did you see it?
I saw highlights of it.
And you're in for a treat,
but it might be more shocking if a guy
like Kim took that much time off and came
back and was as good as he's ever been.
You know,
it's almost like we expect from the
greatest heavyweight of all time.
What do you think is going on,
do you think is the same
thing that happened that
came the same thing to happen
to anybody at a certain time?
Your body point gets older.
Older man,
like father time does not
give a fuck if you're rushing.
When he did throw down when he was stolen,
no shots powers.
The last thing to go Eddie,
he throws him like,
I don't know anybody throws those shelf.
Fuck the way she's
coming down and a spider.
Can you see that?
The power power.
It's the last thing you you'll,
that's why heavyweights last so long,
but he could not got do it out there.
That's,
that's strange.
Who the fuck that?
Let's get a big old spider appeared
to get this white girl in corner.
That was my idea or idea.
That's still a Russian lady.
Gaga right there.
Well,
what I wanted was a little
cultural appropriation.
Poisonous spiders.
Eddie.
That's a,
you're lucky a Pepsi
was seen in that bitch.
That's right.
It's just a black widow.
What's his message man?
Black widows eat their mates.
It's just the like my pussy.
So good.
Who the fuck that off threaten you with?
Uh,
the fear of me killing
you after I fuck you.
That's how hot I am when my song,
I mean,
wait,
who's this?
I don't know.
Say it fade or though
the same fate or God,
Russia's been some dark shit.
Isn't that um,
the uh,
kickboxing gentlemen who knocked out
Badr Hari is that it is Peter Grams.
That Peter Graham
never liked his kickboxing.
I'm sorry.
Just check is still singing.
This is so strange.
I'd like to know if she can sing if fast
forward this a Peter Graham with it.
I think it is who?
Powerful violins.
Violins are very strong instrument.
Chose it.
You have class sophisticated.
Yeah.
How about the track team?
Not Up in here.
Track team.
When you mean the Russian track
teams banned from the Olympics.
Oh,
well,
little cheat cheat.
Well,
getting a little testy.
They said they're going to
check other sports Russia too.
They're going to be fucked.
Something like Olympic Dude
is tweeting at me saying that,
uh,
that I say that uh,
steroids and I'm EPO aren't dangerous and
unlock contrary to what I say steroids
and danger.
And he told her Olympic guy to suck Dick.
Oh well can give gimme danger.
All that stuff's dangerous.
Use too much of it.
If you read the line,
all that shit I can for sure.
It could be doing
anything and be dangerous.
You know,
it's fucking dangerous man.
Cheeseburgers,
Ibuprofen,
really sending your blood
like apparently that stuff,
no,
it's not even a thinning your blood,
it causes all sorts of
issues with your body.
This a nonsteroidal anti inflammatory
medication that a lot of people take all
the time.
Well Cameron Hanes was on that shit.
The dude was running the
hundred miles right now.
Yeah,
he,
he was on that shit.
And then Rhonda Patrick
came on the podcast.
It was talking about how dangerous
it is and all this stuff.
It does.
And he had been like,
he's like,
dude,
I need it.
I'm sore all the time.
Check this out.
He gets off of it and
because he's off of it,
apparently in talking to
people that understand it,
it,
it affects your gut bacteria
when you take too much of it.
If you abuse it,
he was taking 800
milligrams in the morning,
800 milligrams at night.
It's just too much.
So it was raising,
his blood pressure was doing all
this shit to him and it was creating
inflammation is gut
because he was abusing it.
It was fucking with his joints.
So he gets off of it
because of that podcast.
All the pain that he's taking the fucking
medication for in the first place goes
away because the pain had been partially,
at least because of the fact she's,
he's creating inflammation
by taking this shit.
So is,
I mean this guy was running so often,
it didn't make any sense.
I don't understand blood pressure.
I don't understand what like why
do you get high blood pressure?
Why do you not?
I don't understand it,
but I do know that he
gets off this Ibuprofen.
He's doing the same thing in every
other way and all of a sudden his blood
pressure drops.
Jesus.
That's crazy.
That's nuts.
So this guy who is,
uh,
doing the commentary for this thing
apparently was the funniest fuck that man
says he's the best.
I was listening to one
thing that he was saying.
It was hilarious,
man.
I to,
if they would let us listen and
UFC you probably polar shit.
Really?
Yeah.
It's five past.
We got to get permission.
They don't trust.
He could talk your boy data permission.
Too much.
Dang Jar to be association.
I didn't give you permission.
Oh,
maybe.
Maybe something like this,
right?
Yeah.
Fatal.
It's five pounds.
I should have asked it in advance.
I don't want to bother him.
She's got a lot of planning to do.
How is it that the UFC
200 is still together?
How is it that something
catastrophic hasn't happened?
I've cards too.
God damn good.
You just jinxed it.
No,
no,
no.
Not really.
If that card goes through
though exactly as planned,
it will be left to fall out.
It's still the best,
the best card of all time.
Even if four fallout,
we're still good,
but what I'm thinking is villain.
How weird would it be if nothing
fell out like that's how crazy.
This fucking sport is.
Nuts.
This sport is so wild and so volatile
that you got to accept the fact we all do.
Like when rumble just pulled out,
Glover,
we all accept the fact that man,
there's like a certain,
there's a certain amount of fights
that just are not going to happen.
Nothing he could do about it.
Literally nothing.
You do nothing.
He was part of the sport,
part of the sport.
It's just too crazy.
It's too crazy.
It's too dangerous.
Training suit.
Tav trainings too bad on the
joints in the neck and God,
what did rumble pull out from that?
This or does this?
Jamie,
this is
your first fight of the nights.
Jim Miller verse Tuck.
Noreaga go me.
This is fun.
You Diego Sanchez and Joe Lowe's on Pam.
Second fight of the night moves saucy
and that's on fight pass pre cards.
Have you seen Enrique
Mart and fight or Marin?
Excuse me.
I have not.
Enrique Marin and the guy
was fighting sage Northcutt.
I don't know him.
Enjoy that sage enough north gut though.
What do you mean by that?
Meaning and sage north earthen
rip your face off with his abs.
You're on UFC 200 for a
reason because your names.
Oh,
you never know son.
You never know.
Sage northcutts there for a reason.
Wow.
Interesting a great card though.
Dan.
You didn't think that way about pass
fight pass card they've ever had.
God Damn Amazing Pass card ever.
Right then.
You will never do better than that.
How about cats?
Ghana and Julianna Pena.
Holy Shit.
That's going to be a wild fight,
man.
That main cards.
Fucking nine Velasquez.
Travis Browne,
Josie Aldo,
Frankie Edgar,
Misha Tate,
Amanda Nunez,
Brock Lesnar,
Mark Hunt,
Daniel Carme,
a Jon Jones.
People are going to have a heart attack.
Dana White.
Nah,
that's a hard tack card.
By the time you get to the main event,
you're dead.
You know it's crazy.
Joe,
what?
I'm going to say it without Brock Lesnar.
Mark Hunt.
That card's not that big of
a bang or paper view wise.
It doesn't beat a con card or Rhonda Card.
Maybe that's why they come in.
Yeah.
That's why they sent that bat signal.
Brock Lesnar came over from WWE.
Well,
you know what?
There's a reason why they pay that money.
You don't.
They did too.
They played a very,
very smart move strategically
because he's the biggest paper.
If you starve all time,
numero uno,
that flat top good for him.
So when Conor McGregor comes along and
Conor McGregor in the UFC have some sort
of a disagreement about things,
would it be that is their fucking
four aces that they lay down?
Oh,
did they pay for it?
Yeah,
there's definitely some pain,
Yo.
Yeah.
How much?
I don't know.
Probably a lot.
Right?
Let's I what?
From what I hear is the most
the fighters ever been paid.
How much do you think that is?
Color makes more than 5 million.
Ron Carter made a million.
Apparently Kai was the first MMA
athlete to ever enter into Forbes 30,
30.
Yeah,
whatever the top third is,
hot paid athletes top or whatever
the hell he was and all of those.
Number one.
Yeah.
And then there was,
um,
the other guy,
what's the,
uh,
the,
the soccer player Rinaldo's number one.
Yeah,
but there's the other guy,
Massey.
Yeah,
he's up there Brazilian soccer player
from like 10 years ago and all those guys
finish that Brazilian
a portrait.
You remember that guy
from like 10 years ago?
The Brazilian guy superstar.
Not that too.
There's some bad ass
soccer players these days.
They make a lot of money,
man.
It's crazy.
You know,
we don't think about it because in
the United States it sounded big sport
because sport in the world,
it's giant.
Ronaldo and Messi.
You're number one.
And number two,
Ian Edwards has been getting me into it.
I've been trying.
It's,
it's,
it's fun.
I mean,
it's tough.
Strong.
I stutter.
Struggle's real.
So here we,
or just walked into the cage there.
That's the top paid athletes in the world.
Fucking good for you.
Tiger Woods at fucking number 12
and you're making 46 million a year.
Wow.
Could you haven't done shit.
He's on competing right now.
Damn.
Cam Newton,
Lebron James' son,
77 fuck,
fuck you Joe.
Flacco.
Joe Flacco.
Fuck you.
Holy Shit.
Jesus Christ.
Keep going down.
God Damn.
They're like fuck you.
But he like,
man,
he makes more than Joe Flacco.
This isn't these numbers or
banana damn come Gary name.
Yeah.
Conor McGregor is like 34 or something.
Go down there and see what it is.
It's,
he's at 22 million to more than nine
years for for some reason there is no 34
whoa.
It's a fucking lucky number.
They kicked them out.
Maybe there was a tie
somewhere on the list.
Probably.
We're both guys are going to say a
number at the top 50 he's up there.
There's no UFC fighter and the
contras down in the 22 so it's,
I guess it's a hundred is it a Forbes
100 is it four is 100,000 and a UFC
fighters on there it is right there.
There he is.
22 million.
That's interesting.
A lot of guys in this 20 to
20 he's number one and he's,
what is that 85 in the world?
All those sports.
The call these people like Jimmy
Johnson likes $22 million a year.
Wow.
Good for them.
Canelo he makes more than
Canelo and Canelo is now low.
Such a base.
See the biggest guy in boxing right now.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Right?
Well they see the biggest
guy in boxing a straw.
No,
he's dumb.
Cause the biggest dragon has
[inaudible] name another star.
Really inbox right now.
Now that Mayweather's gun.
Well Amir Khan before that fight,
but that,
that was a big victory for Canelo.
Canelo still the bigger
draw the right numbers wise.
Miguel Kodo is still a big,
Miguel Cotto was another example of a
guy was like super tatted up and he's a
world championship caliber fighter.
Like that's a,
that's a real rare back in the day.
That's a real new,
super tatted up,
real,
real tatted up and became more and
more tatted up as his career went on.
That's true.
Do you ever see what
I'm homeboy looks like?
Um,
the white dude from,
uh,
Youngstown,
oh,
you're talking about Kelly Pavlik,
Kelly Kelly attitude.
He's just bodies covered a super tight,
just went nutty with it.
You know,
who is the suit he's a young kid.
Does is silly.
It's skateboarding.
He looks cut.
Do you see what Bobby Green did?
Tattooed his head?
It's not like a dragon on his head.
Well,
okay.
There it goes.
Like guys can do it exactly the same.
He was right.
He looks exactly the same.
They both got dad bought.
Um,
they both got set of tits on him.
It's interesting because they're
in the neighborhood there.
No,
that's the neighborhood Joe.
No matter if I came over dude's house
and he looked like that and he had Bobby
Green.
There's this,
any on his pants off and he
has knuckles clenched up.
I'd be very nervous to for the shoulders.
It looks like those what a,
yeah,
there's Bobby Greens head look at
Eddie fedoras never had an ass.
Barbara Green tattooed his whole,
what do we know what it is?
I don't know.
Professor Athlete or bus.
My man.
You ain't working at remax.
We're looking like that.
It's good looking guy.
He does shut the fuck.
Don't hate,
I'm not hating.
I'm taking it on their out of it.
Is it is the Dragon?
What is that German dude?
I celebrate that Shit.
No idea.
I'm trying to figure it out.
It looks like some sort of dragon.
Yeah,
something like that.
It looks dope.
Wish I could do that.
Could not.
Well,
well what's his face?
Uh,
Jason Ellis has the craziest
ones because it's so intense.
It's so intense.
Jason.
I never seen Jason Ellis.
She said I was tattooed a
wolf on the top of his head.
Let me see the Werewolf.
Oh,
his whole head is like a wolf.
Look at liquid hook
and he's white as fuck.
There's a bunch of pictures of that Jamie,
where he could see a straight on shot.
We could see the actual wolf.
That's a wolf dude.
Look at that.
That's his head.
So intense.
It's so crazy.
Looks good though.
I love it.
Only certain people can pull that off.
He's,
he did it.
He pulled it off.
It's the same guy to me.
Look at all these people like excited
about watching his fate or fight.
That might be the new shit.
Shaved your head and tattoo
it or build like his guys.
Make it look like Karen
me tattoo that fade to fe.
Tattooed.
Imagine you have to have
a good design though.
You can't have like hello
kitty hair designed.
It doesn't go out of style.
You can't tattoo a mullet.
What if you have a whole menu
of what's going on in there?
What does that,
is that,
is that a bad ea or a boozer?
Carlos Buhler.
Boozer is that real?
He tattooed his whole head like spray.
No,
he went ahead and spray paint that shit.
Oh Wow.
I don't weird.
He looks fucking terrible.
I hope that that catches
on and that'd be cool.
I've seen some really bizarre head pieces
that have been done like people have a
over the last few years that's been
more and more common and do like these
really crazy art pieces on your head.
Is it easier for black hair?
Bobby Green.
Excuse me sir.
Don't fuck.
Look at this.
We're watching fader and Maldonado and
fader was just swinging for the fences.
Man,
look at this holy and and I was
covering up in Malden dollars,
moving,
standing right in front of them and fade
or just blew a giant wad and Maldonado
duct and covered and blocked.
A lot of that will fade or
definitely unloaded on him so much.
Knock out
39 impersonator looked like
this fade or just swing and man,
this is crazy.
Maldonado's blocking.
A lot of that stuff comes down the street.
This drug,
this all time.
Look at their bodies.
It's still there is he has to make sure
you eat ice cream and I checked your
blood.
There's no ice cream.
Real life.
Everyone's eat the hot dogs all day.
All Denado is bleed.
No left.
Oh,
there it is.
He's,
he's out.
Oh my goodness.
He is.
They're stopping this.
The
sparks flying there,
man.
That's amazing.
He's a baptist stuff.
Oh my God.
Dude.
I'm like
legs and both time,
but God damn it.
You have,
the brain can only take so much.
The head can only take so much.
I do it.
What are you doing,
man?
What do you mean into the clothes?
What are you going to do with the UFC
if his life outside of this is probably
not as fun if you're best friends,
fucking Putin.
Putin likes to see victory Puente,
his best buddy.
Deep and Russian girls is a good time.
I don't know.
I shot vodka mock Russia,
Russia.
This is a beat down,
man.
It's an ugly Pete down.
He's getting boxed in to get fucked up.
Oh.
Oh my God.
No,
no man.
I mean he's moving.
He's moving,
so look at it.
Oh my God.
There's 100 oh my God.
100% stop us in the UFC.
Oh my God.
Shit.
I can't.
Oh my God.
How about the that?
I bet the forums were going
nuts when this is happening.
Oh.
Oh my God.
All denials.
Beating the shit.
This is worse than I thought it was.
Wave or oh my God,
this is horrific.
Oh,
oh.
How is he surviving?
Oh my God.
What are fatal or get?
She gets came.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Excuse me.
Come on.
Oh Oh
thing is federal comes UFC.
They tossed him fucking,
oh my God.
So I'm a normal dude.
You get no monster.
Oh my God.
What are the craziest
fights I've ever seen?
Oh my God.
Oh,
how bad.
He's still fucking still
getting bobbin that head moving.
He must be so determined
not to lose like this again.
Look,
the dropped again.
The emperor is a fucking monster.
Boy.
He has taken some horrible shots.
The Russian Zombie.
You're fucking batshit crazy.
You think that Russian judge
or ref is stopping anything?
He didn't want to die.
If you're a journalist,
you write bad shit about fader or you die.
This is so,
uh,
it's so weird to watch him like this
now and think about when he was in his
prime.
Oh my God.
Well you to bump this up.
You know what their day
just fucking gave that ref.
Oh my God.
A new car.
You know what I mean?
The mob.
It's funny in this show.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Leave this.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Maldonado,
that nasty apricots modem box to me.
Fuck Aa can only hurt Glover.
Yeah.
And they got dealt with.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
He's uppercuts.
What did they do at rough?
Said let's put this up.
Let's give him a break.
What did he do there?
Got Him another car.
Oh my God.
Oh,
upper cut.
Another one.
Fatal.
Tried to crazy knee fader swings back.
Look at them and saw Austin.
We're strictly cause he
going to go three rounds.
This is incredible and amazing.
The power fade or possesses
and has flied in us.
Have you ever seen such
a powerful flat ass?
That's a very good point.
Right?
So I'm just going on as a tiny ass.
Most guys that much power.
I have fucking cheek
son because look at how,
why to shoulders are,
yeah,
I know no ass.
That's where all your power comes from.
Well you know the thing is you
don't need that much power.
You just need to land with power.
Right?
Like the difference between the guy
who's got like stupid one punch knockout
path Johnson.
Yeah.
And it got close to be as though
cheeks but Faye doors knocked like um,
what's his face?
The grim reaper.
Fuck's his name.
Grim reaper do.
Um,
in,
uh,
give me a hint in strike force
talking about Brett Rogers Rodgers,
right,
exactly.
He didn't call himself the grim reaper.
I don't think so.
Did he,
did he breadth the grim reaper Rogers.
That's,
that's a nice ring to make that up.
No,
that has a nice ring.
Somebody call him that he did it
and I hope it comes back and fights.
Is that,
has that name?
No,
I made it up.
What's that?
The grim.
Okay.
I'm sorry Doug Graham.
But he thought,
oh my God,
look at this phase.
Brandon,
I think,
I think it's just the shorts for Bikini's
on you would see a little bubble.
But remember Brett Rodgers knocked out
Andrea Lawsky and the first round and he
was really good and I think he fought
fade or after that if I'm correct.
That's right.
He thought he'd beat Andre.
And then it was a big high profile fight,
but it was a tough fight for Fado before
he bombed on him with a right hand.
And there was an interesting fight because
one of his trainers just like fate or
one with his old tricks,
but really like you need
to be training and there,
remember Brett Rogers Fret over him.
He fought Uber.
Uber even fucking thrown to the mat.
Ubering was terrifying back then and said,
hey,
Brett Rogers,
sweet knock out of our
Lawsky here's feed or Uber,
Rheem.
Enjoy this.
You're going to go away now.
You know what?
I don't enjoy an MMA.
That overhead shot.
Oh,
the right hands.
Maldon Nanos got a nice short right hand.
Who can that Jab fitters
thinking right now?
God Damn it.
Wow.
Maldonado way looked at like double jab
fate to the face and a jab to the body.
Nice and loose.
He's a good boxer,
man.
Yeah,
really good box.
Ooh,
barely clipped.
Fade on the out.
Faders faces a mass too,
man.
He's such a warrior.
Can rush it out and be okay
that he tries to find neon him.
God Damn,
he's a savage man.
Shows you how far the sport's come though.
When I watch this stuff,
my God damn.
It's nuts.
Like watching Wonderboy is nuts,
man.
Oh,
it's a different thing,
but it's also a different
weight class as well.
There's never been anybody in this weight
class that can move like wonder boy
damn magic and his ass.
Oh my God.
Fit or the come back strong.
They're both exhausted.
You have a fader was the Atlanta
in some good shots there.
Ooh,
nice length fillers.
Fucking them up.
Well,
here's a diversity of fair doors attack
versus Maldon Donald's boxing fader
control.
So it's just been a box too though.
Yeah.
Oh Hey.
Did you just use not that bad.
He's,
he's good at getting back up mirror.
Mild.
No.
You of the body all the time in the UFC.
Is he a brown belt Eddie?
I don't know what it is.
Why don't I feel like he's a brown belt?
Fabio Maldonado Jujitsu.
Find out what it is.
He,
Oh shit.
Now I can't see fit or
I can do everything man.
You know.
And this is the NASA space.
He against heavy bag though.
He's exhausted.
He is.
But I mean fader was really good at,
look at his adjustment.
He's decided to fight on the outside,
start kicking now.
And then these found the
weakness in Maldonado,
his range,
he's fighting way farther apart now.
Look at him cause he got ate up by some
of those punches and so you got such a
good job.
Oh beautiful.
So was coming in with these punches,
but he's on the outside with those kicks.
See I think this distance he
changed the whole distance game.
I think anyone in the top
10 would eat his fight.
Maybe now.
But God damn it,
I'm watching.
This shit almost makes me upset.
That's what I'm saying.
I lied or man,
no,
I'm not saying that pride in the UFC
didn't come to some sort of an agreement
early,
early on and we could've seen fade or
like cro cop fade or add his best fight
against the best heavyweights
and he mean very well.
May have been the best
for quite a few years.
Most likely was most likely,
most likely.
I mean,
it's all,
it's all speculative and totally
actually fights a guy like Cain.
But God damn,
he was good.
Maldonado was a brown belt boom.
Beautiful fucking combination for memory.
Harmful.
Ooh,
look that right.
Jesus Christ.
He looks good.
I'm talking about those really guys
blue,
but the k doors,
he's,
he's landing some colorful show shit.
You,
you,
you sympathize with him because he beat
bay doors ass and he got tired from it.
Nothing.
They don't got the ass kicking.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
No.
He's one on the other
side of the punishment.
I got feed or um,
I mean he's hitting on some really good
shots towards the end of this round.
I think it's his round.
100% of them are small punch this round.
No.
Yes,
he did in the beginning.
Very beginning.
He hit him with good shots,
but Fado has definitely taken over
this round or set 100% of first round.
He lost 10,
eight.
I don't give a fuck you from Russia.
Egypt.
That's 10 me.
It might be 10,
seven man.
It might be 10 cigs if
we're in fucking Colorado.
Yeah.
That's weird.
It's weird.
Decide what that is because
that was the Brits attentive.
That was a vicious beat down in
this round is a perfect example.
This is not the beat down
that that first round was,
it's he's who could this
Maldonaldo clipped him.
Draw modern.
I don't fucking clipped him again.
I look at Fader,
his face,
man.
It's a horror mask.
Oh.
Oh my God.
God Damn.
The faders brothers in prison.
Right.
Um,
I think that's what I read last time.
I too.
It's like Marlo Zimmer main new sites.
How to think about it and
then interviewed them there.
Kill them bitches or something.
He killed anybody in the snow.
I think you're making sure that,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Even little snow,
but he's a savage.
He's a super selfish blue.
That ACL.
This is one of the
commentary was at its best.
I don't know what is going on.
What
he fell down,
bitch.
She's showcase trying to create
drama when there is nothing ice.
He's fat.
Fucking five minutes and 50 seconds.
How about you shut that off.
Oh my God.
Yeah
man.
Well fight.
So fader won that round,
but that's a ten nine rounds.
The last round was ten eight hundred
percent I agree 100% even though he got
knocked down.
He still one?
Yeah.
I think you want,
I mean he,
he got clipped any went down,
but he went right back up
and I think mother Russia,
he landed some pretty significant shots.
It was a close round,
but I think I gave it to fade or,
but I'm not a judge and I really don't
know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Did anything terrible at scoring things.
Okay.
I don't think Tufts sports score,
I don't think in some cases
there should be a winner.
You know,
like the boss of your fight both say,
yeah,
I feel good.
That's like that.
Like to say one guy,
one on one guy lost my God.
Damn,
that's so close.
It's so close.
He gets into this gray or,
I mean,
you could say that you
thought that Bossi one.
And I could say that I
thought I'd call and why,
but if you,
if you,
if you look at it all together,
it's like,
man,
it's just a,
it's a guess.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It's a great guy.
Damn fight.
It's so good to see.
You need to watch it again when I'm sober.
Yeah.
I need to watch the whole fight.
I usually do that.
I record them.
I watch them Sunday mornings
when we do the companions.
So this is a third brown.
So I have ten first round for Fabio Hook.
Your favorite?
Favorite.
Wow.
Fay door's busted.
Hot Man.
The greatest of all time.
Right?
What do I still does it?
The only other guy that it's on the
argument about the greatest of all time.
Times cane.
Oh,
how dare you.
What about for doom?
Well,
Pete Kane.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
What about Steepbank?
Yeah.
You know what?
Steep Steep Bay has
the potential for sure.
He's like at the door,
you know Steepbank and hit together.
So do before you can see
as the greatest phone.
No,
no,
no doubt.
But he's,
he's in an advanced place,
right?
Knocked out for doom and a beautiful one.
Punch knockout in Brizzy wobbled
him left with a beautiful left hook.
God damn his boxing is crisp.
I'd say Malo.
Strikings better this fight.
It looks good man.
It does.
It looks more Chris.
Well,
he also knows this is
super dangerous opponent.
Oh my God.
Oh Nice.
Your body by freight door.
Still quick as fuck.
Oh Man.
Combo.
Beautiful Combo by fate
or really isn't dropped.
Oh God.
Mom and clipped him again with the left.
Hook them up.
That left hook on the outside.
Oh,
the jab.
God damn all done.
Otherwise are good fucking striker.
You know,
it's,
it's one of those things
where you gotta wonder like,
is this what fate or wants to do?
Is this like an exciting fight for
Ramsey and join this or is this a,
is it a financial decision?
You feel like it's diminishing his legacy?
No,
not to me.
To me it's just this is who he is.
This is not what he's done.
Just a fighter.
What he's done is just fucking,
you can't take that away from them.
Yeah.
I mean if you go always be
PAMF pound one or two for me.
Heavyweight.
Oh yeah.
I think one,
yeah.
For me as a case.
He does have a case,
but the thing is,
I don't know,
a fader was the same guy by
the time he got divert doom.
I mean it's total speculation.
I also think,
you know,
guys taught long and errors,
man.
I agree.
Because you look at what Kane did,
amber doom,
they're also facing I think
more well rounded guys.
Yeah.
Good shot to the bottom.
Evolution of the sport.
100%.
But you know,
when you're looking at all time greats,
don't you think that Muhammad Ali
is the greatest boxer of all time?
Do for bevy ways,
ins,
right?
But if you yeah,
like for socially.
Yes.
Yeah.
And what he stood for over pop culture,
all that.
What do you think that
he would have survived?
Mike Tyson,
the Mike Tyson.
The beat Marvis Frasier.
Yeah,
I do.
Maybe,
but did you ever watch Henry
Cooper knock them down?
Yeah,
they're like the same age
when Henry Cooper knocked,
uh,
Tyson down,
or excuse me,
Muhammad Ali down and um,
uh,
we're talking,
we're talking Muhammad Ali
before the draft bullshit.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
This is death.
This was when he was Cassius clay.
When he sketched clay,
he beats Mike Tyson
afterwards where it's tough.
Yeah.
It's hard to say man.
That's a thing,
right?
It's like when do you catch the guy?
Like when you look at this fade or you
can't judge this fade or in the third
round of this fight with Fabio
Maldonado who's been beaten up,
his eyes are almost won.
This is not quite the same guy as
the guy who we saw just armbar.
Kevin Randleman have to get super relaxed.
The guy that we saw come back against
Fujita Fujita caught him on the big punch,
came back.
There was no Garrett grounding pal.
Yeah man.
It was no camera.
That's what the time,
cause remember Verdomme fought in pride
and he would have eight fucking ver
dooms lunch back then but for doom
now with list his fucking head off.
I think there are different guidance
to say for doom now is on the,
he's still at the very highest level.
I mean we've got to see how he rebalanced
for Steve Bay knock out cause it was a
brutal knockout.
But before that fight,
if you look at his knock out and Mark
Hunt and if you look at a submission
victory over a cane,
you're looking at like the best version.
You think about junior dos Santos in his
prime against fade or fight junior dos
Santos is prime in his prime.
His father came stuff.
But I'll tell you what dude,
he looked really fucking
good and his last one great.
He did look really good.
You look great.
Shocking,
right?
Amazing.
Really good.
I mean a lot of people thought that
Ben Rothwell had the answer to his uh,
boxing style with his,
you know,
Ben is just awkwardness.
Real awkward and dangerous.
Like super dangerous was knockout
power dealt with and also like really
confident.
You know,
Ben is just a real savage
and super experienced guys.
Been around for a long time.
Huge,
huge,
enormous,
like one of the biggest like physically
Busiek biggest guys in the heavyweight
division.
Like just how busy we are,
how big he was.
And even at Wayne's I was like,
he's not that big.
They want to get knocked
down like Jesus Christ.
What the fuck am I doing it heavyweight.
He's so big.
Enormous.
And Harry,
he's so big that he did.
He like,
there's no doubt he could not make
two oh five you look at me go wide.
These are real heavyweight fights.
I like to be lost a row or like,
Hey,
what do you think your two of five?
No Man,
what do you think of 300 yeah,
he's the argument for the weight class.
Yes,
it's got his hands down.
Boom,
boom.
He's exhausted.
I think man.
But he a lot of times he fought like that.
He never moved like that,
but he's just a,
you know,
I mean you got to consider the beating
that he took in that first round,
but if you remember like
the cro cop that used to,
there it is.
That's the end.
That's it.
Yeah.
I first round ten nine six
[inaudible] 10 I mean first round,
ten eight second around
ten nine this friend,
I don't fuck,
he won this round two seems like a draw.
I would,
I would assume that it's draw.
If I was a,
if I didn't know the score,
he jumped up on the ring
like he for sure had it.
Well,
you know he fought well.
I know in that first round
he did second 30 days.
Hill faded would be undecided
in a couple of shots in there.
We'll fade or definitely came back in
that second and his reign draw his range
was better.
Yeah,
I would say that that's a
reasonable to call that a draw.
If I was watching this
and I was objective,
there's never good Madoff
in the house either.
Draw them all Dinaro
line either at the draw.
I'm all denial.
Yeah,
I don't see,
yeah,
I agree.
And the damage,
well there's no way that fate or the
second or the third by any more than ten
nine if you had the
standard scoring system,
we're getting dropped.
Last hook he grabbed,
he cracked him,
he cracked.
Even in these rounds,
he's still hurt,
fade or more than feed or hurt him or
hit him or fate or it hit him with some
good shots.
Those second and third rounds,
but he wobbled,
fade are in the second round
riding on the shoulder a lot too.
He's,
yeah.
Well there was a nice ride,
man.
Look,
it's a good fight,
you know,
and Maldonado rose to the
occasion and for photo,
this is a very,
very,
very difficult fight to gypsy.
When fader would make paintings
and they would sell them on Ebay.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Through a terrible,
people would buy a beautiful paintings.
I even looked at bidding and on one,
did you go to college?
I was like,
yeah,
I want to fade or painting.
It was like a smiley face man.
He's um,
he's all time legend right there.
If your fate or I can just do shit.
I almost bought it.
It was take my fucking paypal.
He's 39 now.
So how old he is.
Yeah.
39 30 he needs to stop all time.
Legend man.
All Time Ledge.
And how old is Dan Henderson?
Dan Henderson is 45 and the goddamn
American treasure just knocked out.
Hector lie the way to
find it for a world title,
by the way.
Knocked out.
Fade or don't forget that.
That's fucking Strikeforce.
Feta.
Does that hook?
He misses any comes back with the elbow.
Oh yeah.
That was some shit.
You can't even put it in a movie.
You can't put that movie.
He would go shut up.
And why is he moved so stiff movie.
He would be like,
I don't believe that this
guy get hit that hard.
Look how he moves.
These are [inaudible] paintings.
Look at this and it.
He's Shitty game up now that he retired.
He's a little more detailed.
I didn't look up there.
Nah,
I don't want that.
Fucking beautiful.
That's a beautiful tweety bird.
Cute little girl.
No,
he got away.
He works with,
I didn't want these.
These are two good.
Let me tell you something man.
We,
we all know he's drawn this shit.
That sad.
No,
cause it looks like his face.
That's crazy.
Listen man,
we all miss something in our world by
Brock Lesnar and fade or never fighting.
I agree.
We all miss something 100%.
We miss a little piece of life.
Two Lane that could have been too late.
That could have been really interesting.
It's still happen.
It could definitely still happen.
Immediate fate or just won this fight.
And if Brock wins his fight,
which is certainly a bigF ,
and if the UFC decides to
sign fade or after this fight,
because to the fans,
like this is a really tough fight,
buddy.
One,
it's still not a loss.
You know,
after you wait a few months,
I'm just saying if I was a salesman,
which check kind of,
that's your thing as what I would say.
I would say,
let's fucking do this.
We've always wanted to see this.
Let's do this.
By the way,
give him a fucking Usada
exemption that playing games,
any games,
give him some turbulence.
You let them take whatever he wants.
He's fighting Brock Lesnar.
Oof.
Let them take whatever he wants.
Let him get some of that fabric in the
report as the north miss a big reporter,
James Bro.
It's like,
why don't you get smaller?
Hmm.
I'd like to see him a fate or go out.
He'd go out and after that,
yeah,
he's his dad.
Giant ass gorilla.
Who's that guy?
Look at his hands.
Jesus.
There are enormous,
you don't want that.
That could be Andrew Karalyn remember
that gets definitely not though.
Drug corral looks like way harder.
He's like,
he's terrifying looking.
Cool Mike.
I don't about that.
Pepsi money.
No,
I don't know what the fuck is that.
See my ultimate ad space.
He was on the mic fucking like a fader.
Well the UFC has like a unit.
We have like a little UFC logo.
That's the show and like a network guy.
But when you have,
what if the UFC had a monster low?
Uh,
Mike,
can you imagine?
But when I do,
he said he was for Fox.
If it's fs one,
it says it on the,
it says Fox on the little thing.
But like a sponsor,
like what do you think that is?
Is that a station?
What is that on his mind?
I think that's Russian.
Pepsi.
Look at that.
It's got to be wow.
Or,
or they,
they just like the same colors.
Brendan Shop.
If you were afraid or his friend,
would you tell him right now?
I would give him a way harsher talk.
Then he gave me,
I would fucking the hey man,
cause I'm sure he has
the options in Russia.
He's a living legend.
He's like Brad Pitt and Russia.
You know what I'm saying?
Did you know that there's like
someone was saying something crazy,
someone sent something to me on Twitter
about him fighting value of next.
That's seven foot tall Russian boxer.
Is that bullshit?
I mean if you take some down.
Sure.
Jamie,
see she's crazy.
Bullshit.
Fucking circus.
I Dunno.
Well fighting giant giant dudes.
They don't know shit in Vegas.
He remembered he did that twice.
He fought Zulu,
who was a huge guy but really charming.
But then he fought Hong Whan Choi
who was at like a seven foot one guy.
He was enormous,
right?
Yeah.
This dude at the Mirage
talk me.
I don't think you would sell tickets.
Three food at night for Friday.
Saturday,
Sunday.
We do a live flight
companion from that bullshit.
I want to be this shit be alive,
get paid.
If we ever get hired by a casino to do
a fight companion in like a large space
and Tiwi enough for now.
Oh my God,
we're going to get shrunk.
Someone's going to kill us for a crazy.
What was I asking you?
This research I caught value of,
I don't know whether or not fade or is
rumored to be fighting value of next
because someone was
saying that on Twitter.
Can you believe he's
going to fight value of,
and I was like,
why?
I think it was Twitter.
Read it somewhere where I read it.
He just needs to stop.
Well maybe it doesn't need to stop or
does he need to do whatever the fuck he
wants to do and this is loves
doing the fuck he wants to do.
This is probably like more fun for him.
That did not look,
they're not telling you,
but came back strong as
fuck in that second round.
This is the first real,
it was the first real
challenge that he's had.
The first guy just could
not grapple with them.
Right.
Take that guy down.
Dominates and when the ground
ground and pounds on this fight,
he gets tested.
So what he's got to do now for shampoos,
take some fucking time off.
Take a long time.
Off.
I think we've taken enough time off.
You've got to heal up
and get your ass back.
You don't get that much time.
But that's not what,
I'm 39 I agree with you 100% but I think
he's got to take some time off from
that beating.
He took a beating dude.
You can't just jump right back in.
You'll be,
you'll still be suffering.
Remember,
remember what Steve Bay did?
Maldona yeah I do.
I do.
Steve Bay is a monster.
You starched and congratulated him in
the ring after this oh value of did and
that's about,
that's it about a fight.
But there was some weird thing where they
cut the value of any made a face cause
a fader was making some sort of a
speech and they cut the value of,
I'm just speaking out of like a,
you know,
bullshit rubric.
Well also like if I had to be skeptical,
I would say probably what they do.
Which Putin there,
that's what it says.
It says my knees.
A notable people came to congratulate
him including Nicholi value.
Evan notably Vladimir Putin.
Putin and him are,
or boys.
Are you scared if Hillary Clinton wins?
Oh Shit.
And I'm more scared if Donald
Trump wins more scared.
Yeah.
I think he's
either way.
You know what?
This is what I think Hillary Clinton a
million percent and is going to win 100%
of them.
Donald Trump is not going to,
they're not going to let him be president.
That was just a big distraction.
They put them in there to
make sure Hillary wins.
For sure.
Trump going to be president.
Well that he's going to be the president.
It's all you think is a sound sensor.
Tower seven.
What do you think you'd think,
uh,
you think that the election was rigged
with Bernie Sanders in California and
Hillary,
you think it was rigged?
You look into it at all.
He didn't into it.
I did not
think it was rigged.
Um,
there's definitely some sort of a
problem with there was votes at weren't
counted,
right?
Yeah.
Pretty much.
That's right.
History and really being in the
Bernie Carlson pull more land to,
hold on.
Eddie,
what?
So yeah.
A friend of mine who I follow on Facebook.
Uh,
he was really big in the Bernie campaign,
uh,
falling a lot of it,
posting things all throughout
the last couple of months.
He was even making posters that
were going viral online for it,
helping voters for
registrations and whatnot.
His vote wasn't counted and it said,
because he didn't sign this thing and
he is adamant that he hundred percent
followed everything to the t double
checked all this stuff they're telling you
is,
but it won't be counted a hundred.
And so what is,
um,
so what's the conspiracy
conspiracy theory?
Is that uh,
um,
that Hillary's campaign is
actively suppressing votes?
Is it that or is it that there's a bunch
of people that are zealous and they,
uh,
they identify with the Hillary Party
and they work some in some way,
shape or form and counting side.
It doesn't count.
That's what that means.
Everyone don't have to be,
oh,
I voted if you didn't vote,
don't fucking complain.
Guess what?
Your phone didn't count.
Right?
No,
I totally get that.
But I'm saying like,
what do you think is the mechanism?
Like what's actually happening here?
Is it because they think
that Hillary's parlor,
so Hillary,
it's like there's some sort of concerted
effort to make her win even though they
know she wasn't wearing.
She's part of the team and she's what
she's can apply no matter what you're
selling,
no matter what.
Here's the question.
Here's a real question.
Who's doing that and how is that,
how is it the people that are working
in the campaign offices and in the
election was the government?
Well,
the people that are working
in election offices,
the people that count elections,
right?
They count results.
They must have some
kind of political bias,
right?
They must meet people do.
Everyone does.
Some people are just naturally democratic.
Some people are naturally conservative.
They'd have to.
How do they account for that?
When it comes to something like this,
like when you have,
what is the excuse,
like what's the,
what is the,
the the reason they're saying
why these votes weren't counted.
Provisional ballots is something I've
heard come up a lot and they're going to
be counted over an
extended period of time.
But they've already made calls for things.
So that,
I don't know how that felt,
but the dude,
you know,
said that his stuff wasn't signed right.
They said he wasn't signed.
Did you take a photo of it?
Screenshot.
I sought,
I think that you said he's got
even eye witnesses that saw him.
He has a,
he has a screen shot of him.
Not a screenshot that it was
a screenshot of like his,
the response to the voter registration
things set that says vote wasn't it?
Oh,
whistleblowers.
Whistleblower came out and made a video.
She made a video and explained everything,
how they trained or what to do.
And what they did is they supposedly,
this is what she said,
that they told her that anybody,
cause you could vote for a candidate
but not be part of a party.
You could just say,
I'm not Democrat.
I'm not a Republican.
I'm a whatever her name.
There's a name for it.
No,
uh,
political,
whatever representation.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but you're,
you're that third,
that third class.
So if most of those people
were voting for Bernie,
so they weren't either,
they weren't Democrat or Republican,
so they were on that third pile and
that third pound on and those votes got
counted.
Whoa.
That's what,
that's what the conspiracy
theory is and that's huge shit.
Huge,
huge.
I mean,
yeah,
that's an,
your vote doesn't count.
Well that's also what
happened during the Al Gore,
George W elections where they said that
if you actually counted the real numbers
of people that voted like all
that dangling Chad Bullshit,
if you actually count the actual
results after they sorted it all out,
Al Gore won.
He won the election.
I mean this is like
pretty well established,
but it's one of those things where you
know how referee stops a fight for the
wrong reason.
Once they stopped the fight,
the fight stopped.
Yeah.
It's nothing.
It's kind of the same
thing with [inaudible].
They're so terrified of this idea of
losing the power that they get from
controlling the leader of the world,
which is exactly what it is.
When you just decided
someone's a president,
if you got to a point where you're like,
this is so stupid,
why are we still having presence?
And everybody agreed there'd be no one
person that would have that position of
power.
They're so terrified of that,
that even in it,
it like some sort of a crazy dispute
where Al Gore like may or may have not.
Obviously I didn't count them,
but if you count them all up and you
listen to a lot of the people that did,
they said that Al Gore won that election.
He should have won that election easy and
like we're not even going to entertain
it.
Just not even going to entertain.
And Adler backs away.
And then the same thing
happened with Carrie didn't,
same thing happened with Carrie.
There was like some dispute as to whether
or not carry one or didn't mean Al
Gore was a,
for sure thing,
k was close.
But Carrie was an issue too.
There was a,
there was some sort of a
dispute with Carrie too.
I think with all those guys,
it's like the game is so fucking wacky.
It's so the game of controlling the
Geo political power of the world and
controlling the greatest nation the world
has ever known and the best people we
can get.
The people that were
we're voting on right now,
it's ridiculous.
All the smartest people aren't going to
run to watch a documentary on Youtube
called behind the Iran Contra affair.
You'll get to see,
this is all public shit.
The Iran Contra affair that shows you
how ever help help people get honey deck.
It shows you everything.
Watch that chronicles,
the Clinton chronicles and
behind the Iran Contra affair.
It's fucking nuts.
Don't get a star on top seven.
Well we don't have to go to that though.
I rent contract fares is undeniable.
It's one of those,
the Iran Contra affair is one of those
conspiracy theories that's so legit and
so verified and so proven that it opens
a door to a lot of other stuff cause you
go,
well wait a minute.
How the fuck did they think
they could pull off this?
How do they,
how did they sell drugs in the La
Ghettos to fund these crazy military
operations?
Nothing centuries,
dude.
What they did,
it was they sold drugs in
the ghetto like they sold,
look,
here's the thing,
if you know,
it was like two dozen people
running all that shit.
They're not that many.
Not that many.
You know?
And that's one of the
things that the CIA guys,
when you,
when you get to know them and you start
communicating with them and realize,
okay,
there's some cowboys that realize that
they're kind of operating on their own
and they realized they could make a
lot of money and they went for it.
And I think that's what happened.
Military connection in a
lot of tape makes it happen.
I think that happened in a lot of cases.
And there's a lot of dudes who sold
drugs and did all kinds of other shit
because there's a lot of other
people doing it and they,
they like,
fuck these people.
Why didn't,
should these people make this money?
And we could take this money.
And we can go do some other shit.
And they got caught with it.
They got caught funding the war with
the contractors and the Sandinistas in
Nicaragua.
That was during the Oliver North trials.
All that crazy shit dude.
It was bananas.
They got comp buffed it.
There's like here,
here it is right here was
the 2004 election stolen
Republican's prevented more
than,
what does that say?
350,000 votes in Ohio
article written by Robert F.
Kennedy Jr in rolling stone.
Whoa.
Kenny Jr.
Yeah,
so you see there's always these
debates and disputes about elections,
but I think at a certain point in time,
like as a people,
we have to come to this conclusion,
this idea of giving all the power
to one group like this is just,
it's intoxicating.
It's dangerous,
it's not good for them.
It's not good for us.
It's not good for anybody.
We Shit,
we shouldn't have these groups that have
so much power over what you do or what
you don't.
And especially like what the fuck
happens with the future of the world?
Like who are these people?
Like why?
Why do they?
Because we decide cause
everybody raises their hand.
They point to a guy,
that guy gets to choose.
This is madness.
We get to stop doing it.
Old School,
it's old school for sure.
Ran Contra scandal was when Ronald Reagan
was president and George Senior was
vice president.
George scene was vice president.
He was the former director of the CIA.
He's right there.
Vice President,
actor fucking president during,
that's when they were,
George Bush was running all kinds
of game through the CIA and uh,
they got caught selling
arms to Iran through Israel.
We were supposedly,
that was,
those were our enemies.
But,
and then they said it was because
they needed a free the hostages.
So that's why they were
selling arms to them.
But sounds like a reasonable deal.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
that's some old shit.
Nothing light him up.
Now the sweet guns check these
out were just making money.
The guys that were handling the deals
that were just skimming all the money and
that they got busted.
So the guys that got indicted,
there was like four dudes.
As soon as George W.
Bush or Jordan,
not w George singer became president,
he pardoned all those guys.
You let them all
out of jail.
It was gangster sleeps fog,
they're gangsters and,
and it's public knowledge and no one can
do anything about it and you just can't
do shit about it.
So crazy.
Like you can't do anything
about any of that shit.
That shit was all public knowledge.
They were,
they had the hearings in front of Congress
on public television for two or three
weeks.
It was huge.
I remember it got busted and guess what?
Nothing.
Guess what?
George senior became president.
How about that?
But I,
gangster movie,
He became president and then he got
his retard son to become president.
He wasn't,
just wasn't.
So how about,
how about this?
How about this?
When he was vice president,
when all that should happen,
so when those dudes got busted,
he pardoned him once he became president
and the guy responsible for all,
for,
for allowing all the drugs to
come in illegally through the CIA.
When Bill Clinton was
Bill Clinton in Arkansas.
He was the governor.
Guess what?
After George singers,
President Bill Clinton,
that takes us,
he was next.
He said,
what's up?
hey,
let us run this shit.
Three a goddamn state
and we'll hook you up.
We'll let you be
president for a few years.
What about that?
It's hard to,
it's hard to argue with facts.
I mean,
Arkansas Gang,
so Barry seal's connection.
Watch the crib.
The Clinton chronicles,
watch that show and said,
dude,
that Clinton Quantico's.
You'll see how it,
when he was,
when Bill Clinton was
governor of Arkansas,
he was gangster.
He was the most gangster.
Oh,
he's got
that soprano guy in the White House.
That's nothing.
That's a no Bill Clinton.
Bill Clinton was,
that's all he cared about was pussy.
That's all I cared about.
And there's whistleblower
after whistleblower.
That's what he was known for.
He got down
clean,
the grind.
The sacs calling that is doing sec.
He was a beast.
He was.
He was like,
what's his name?
Jimmy Soprano.
What's that guy's name?
Tony.
Tony's.
How many guys?
I've done coke in the White House.
They had the best shit.
They brought it in the delta.
They brought it in.
How many people you think what
[inaudible] joint at the White House.
You're crazy.
Don't think Obama smoking joints at night?
No.
You don't want,
I don't know so much weed for sure.
Colin can a paranoia.
Do you think that he would get
if he was smoking weed at night,
he would sleep at night.
What's that?
David Cross admits to snoring.
Starting cocaine at the White House.
He won't be back.
You know what?
That didn't even give a shit.
What the fuck?
They didn't give a shit.
Common care is a comic.
I don't give a fuck.
No.
I'm sure he was telling the truth.
Everybody has.
The CIA is doing all of
these culture operations.
The the cancels,
the NFL,
NBA.
There's some Storton going on.
That's amazing.
They would fucking bring coke into the
White House that had such a [inaudible]
pat pound down celebrities.
Do the people that are
running the patterns that
party and harder than anybody
who is
just like,
that's real,
bro.
It's documentary.
It's on youtube.
No,
it's at the library.
My Shit on Youtube.
I watch it on science dot.
What?
Hulu.
Amazon.
What were we just talking about?
He says Youtube and then
did you watch it on Youtube?
It's like,
where else are you gonna fucking watch it.
Hulu.
Hulu is a fine platform.
Snoop Dogg says he smoked marijuana
in the White House without Obama.
Without Obama.
Yeah,
probably.
That's a good move.
It's on here too,
man.
I don't believe it.
If it was on Vimeo,
I would believe that.
We're cnn.com what?
Jamie?
I need a an APP.
Willie Nelson.
There's a bunch.
You wish Brian Cowen didn't leave.
Then you and him could get into it.
My loves Clinton.
I'm done with the tower south.
Fast.
You're over.
You're over with
is how people can watch that shit
and and still not believe it.
That's more fascinating.
What's behind that shit that,
that's what I want to know.
That's what I want to know.
It's like,
fuck.
How the fuck does that happen?
How do you get hypnotized?
You could see that shit coming down,
but yet you still think it came down.
The fire is more Pepsi
people reached out to me,
bro.
How do you make for your
buddies beliefs like that?
It's no different like,
hey man,
I'm not offended,
but which is the conversation?
Just debating.
I don't believe in dragons.
You guys don't make fun of
me going up to hypnotism,
man.
I want to.
I want to know everything about that shit.
I want to know about Mkl
tron on mind control stuff.
That's what I'm into.
That shit.
That shit work.
Dope headlights on that car.
Look at that shit is Formula One car.
That's the hazards mass.
That portion.
That thing is nine seven nine whatever.
Rsa 19 is that what it is?
The new one?
Look at that thing.
Those tires can't be cheap.
You know what?
There's a weird thing that happens when
they switched to these insane shapes.
His tires can be,
he's just tired because I have 100 bucks.
Oh fuck.
Serves their sponsor.
Oh No,
no.
They don't pay for them.
But if you had to pay for 500 more
than a grant to go through it and like
fucking a half more than a grant attire
for those because they have to be,
they have to be rated to
go over 200 miles an hour,
not burn.
Those things are insane.
They're all slicks,
you know,
they don't have any tread on them.
That's the thing about those tires.
They're like this really soft
sticky component and so they,
they kinda like drive with them and heat
them up and move around with them and
then once they heat them up real good,
they become super adhesive.
Yeah.
Real sticky.
And you could just take you down.
No,
no.
Stick to the crib to
the road like a Gecko.
It's way better because
you don't get as retired.
See that Jamie?
That's Nascar dog.
I'm talking about f one son.
It's got to be very,
let's say three different
kinds of four 50 leech.
Interestingly,
racing teams don't buy their tires.
They leased those,
they leased them from good year.
The official tire supplier
of Nascar on race day.
Each team is allowed to lease 16 sets
of four tires for this guy matter.
How crazy that 16 sets they,
it takes them 16 sets a fucking,
that's a lot of fun.
Well that's because those
things are super gummy man.
So like the really good racers,
they know when their tires
are like ready to go,
they start feeling the slippage.
They start,
they're so sensitive and it's
like really like their ass,
like their ass and their
feet and their feet,
their hand connected to the wheel.
They go,
Oh this bitch is slip and just a little
bit more than it did the last lap.
How's that back Eddie?
Oh,
I'm gonna go home and fucking,
yeah.
Midtown is this,
uh,
would you want to try one of these chairs?
Is this,
what do you think this would be better?
Is that one allow you to like
lean back a little bit more?
What's better?
It's okay for seven hours.
I'm after you.
Compromise soon.
Brothers is ridiculous.
Why are we still doing this?
We've been going since seven 30.
How much time do we do?
This is going to be a five hour pod.
Which is so ridiculous.
Let's break it up into two pieces.
I have part one.
God were so ridiculous.
We should shut the fuck a
couple of guys having fun man.
See,
look at this guys sliding backwards.
Tell me that looks like a good time
and this guy is slamming into one.
He's Asian.
You don't know that.
You just being rude but are no
Asian Nascar drivers though.
That's a good point.
Yeah,
we thought about that shit in
2003 he's guaranteed a ruck.
Know what I mean?
That brings in the people.
That's what they want to see bro.
He's 61 years old.
No,
no wonder he's fun.
He's you think Shit
Nass Nascar should like,
they should go for that.
What's that?
There's just one there is about you.
Eddie Bravo.
You don't even reach Eddie.
Probably cry.
I'm sorry.
Asians.
Out there.
And we were just joking around because
I'll sketch that we did on the man show
that got rejected.
It's a long day.
A lot of podcasts and all right folks.
So I guess that's it.
We'll wrap this up.
I hope you guys enjoyed
the fuck out of it.
We did.
I enjoyed the fuck out of it.
A Bravo.
You're gangster for getting here.
Uh,
Cameron Hanes at last update was over 70.